you don't just not say anything that
is rude as do you understand
that
everybody else
out of my company that's what I did to
my nephew HR just
oh boy I told my own blood to go
himself it's like that's not cool yeah
so what are you gonna do to me yeah
nothing I like you I hate my family yeah
oh okay yeah no sorry you're cool man
sorry about this I'm so pissed off about
my nephews yeah that's why I'm in such a
bad sorry I'm triggered man you did
something that reminded me of my nephew
and it reminded me the time when I
kicked him in his nuts you know
you have to kick your own blood in the
balls
you gotta Jam your foot and your
nephew's nuts you know how that goes
it's weird because they're small because
he's young you know he's only 15. I
kicked him in the balls one of them
wasn't there my toe went up in his body
my toe was looking for the nut in his
stomach anyway sorry man you're cool
yeah you're cool so uh let's talk about
that race